[Music]
we got a question from facebook
kim has a question for us i heard tk say
what pisses you off is your biggest clue
to the very possibilities that you are
here to bring forth so when i get pissed
off by my husband because he never does
anything on his to-do list how am i to
bring that forth
okay this is
explicitly for you this is so good this
is so good
i i think that phrase bring something
forth is probably uh
a little bit more metaphysical and
mystical sounding than i intended it to
be uh it's kind of like we had a
conversation of the week where i said
manifestation is a perfectly fine word
that's only guilty by association
uh it just means to produce
it just means to make happen it just
means to create a result so
substitute any word that has anything to
do with making something happen
exercising influence on your environment
having causative power and that'll do
for the phrase bring bring it forth uh
let's talk about kim's husband though
but yeah let's talk about it so so first
let's back up and just lay a quick
foundation
the context for that observation is this
anytime you have a so-called negative
emotion two fundamentally different ways
you can react to it the way of
self-condemnation or the way of
self-discovery the way of
self-condemnation is when you say i'm a
bad person for having the capacity to
feel this way and you tend to wallow in
guilt and self-pity the way of
self-discovery is when you say my ethics
are not determined by my emotions but
rather by how i react and respond to
what i feel in the moment i am not a
good person or a bad person because of
what i feel but because of what i do
with what i feel and i'm encouraging
people when they feel anger don't wally
wallow wally don't wallow in guilt and
self-pity but instead use it as an
opportunity for self-discovery because
your anger
reveals to you something about your
priorities your preferences and your
principles how can we know this simply
by observing the fact that not everyone
gets as angry as you do about the things
that anger you your anger tells you
something unique about you because for
everything that irritates you there are
people in this role who don't even
notice that that's happening there are
people who don't care about that at all
so it says something about you and it
says that you have certain expectations
assumptions values needs and desires
that are unique to you and if you can
take what angers you and use it as an
opportunity to discover the positive
vision for how you want the world to be
that that anger symbolizes or captures
for you it puts you in a position where
you can actually do something about it
not just because you have a positive
vision but because since you are the
person that gets angry about that you
actually will have the energy and the
motivation to do something about it so
if it annoys you that people are messy
and unorganized that means you have a
passion for order you have a passion for
the value of neatness and when you see
something that conflicts with that it
bothers you when you see people being
mean to each other and that angers you
that means you have a passion for
kindness and humanity and dignity and
generosity and that means you are
optimized to help create a world to be
more like that vision you have now
here's the thing about changing the
world
in order to change the world you have to
give up your expectations about what
parts of the world are going to change
in response to what you have to offer
sometimes when we have a passion
we get attached to the notion that our
family will appreciate that passion or
that our friends will respect that
passion but it might very well be the
case when you follow a passion all the
people that grew up with you all the
people that know you all your family and
friends might be completely bored and
unimpressed by your passion and it may
be some stranger across the country who
says thank you for saying that thank you
for creating that it's just what i
needed and so i think it's very
dangerous business
to look at this in a way that says all
right great i'm gonna use anger as a
tool for self-discovery i'm gonna
identify the fact that i have a passion
for productivity i have a passion for
being consistent with your word i have a
compassion for getting things done and
now what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna use
this passion to change my husband
because the very fact that you are
attached to changing him is going to
make him resist it
it's only when you are non-attached
florence coppola shin said your ship
comes in over a no-care sea you know
the more you try to change a particular
person the more that person is going to
resist it and be like no i don't want it
from you so you have to find a way to
embody and represent the passions and
values that your anger are a clue for in
a general sense in everything that you
do and everything that you say and how
you treat all people and maybe your
husband will be one of the people who
changes but maybe not but if you're true
to who you are and who you're meant to
be someone in this world will be
influenced by you and you know it just
may not be the people that you want it
to be but that's okay um if you love
your husband
and you need to change him you don't
actually love him right
because
to want to constantly change someone
is to unlove them it's to set up
standards now you might not like this
thing about his to-do list and i totally
get that i learned something from ryan
he really helped me out with this
that if i have some sort of expectation
like bex i would like for her to put the
paint up now that she's done painting
this little
shelf area of the house and she doesn't
do it i can i have a few options here
one is i can get mad yeah and to just go
stew in a room by myself go punch a hole
in the wall right show that wall who's
boss i can get yeah i can rage that's
another another outcome
i can
bring it to her and say why didn't you
do this
or
there's a fourth option here
why not do it myself amen if it's my
problem yeah why don't i put up the pain
why don't i do the to-do list so maybe
it's not that
there is a to-do list that i've given to
her that she now needs to complete
maybe she needs help with that to-do
list in order to live up to my standards
that i'm setting because maybe she's
already living up to her standard and if
she did need help
i know she'd ask yeah you know can i say
one more thing on this is uh
i think if we if we understand just how
much
our own anger says something about our
unique form of brilliance and beauty
that anger can then be turned into
inspiration sometimes we wallow in anger
because we underestimate ourselves so
for instance let's say you get mad at
people who just um
maybe um
maybe they never show up on time or
maybe they never study
maybe they never challenge themselves it
could be the case that you are
underestimating just how gifted you are
or just how advantaged you are it could
be the case that something is something
that is of value is really valuable uh
really obvious to you and it's not
obvious to other people and instead of
getting mad at other people for not
being like you you could say whoa wait a
minute
there's something important about life
that's super obvious to me or natural
for me
maybe that's one of the things that
makes me unique
maybe that's one of the things that
makes me able to bring value to this
relationship and now when you can let go
of that anger at the other person and
just embrace your own beauty you're free
to get curious you see your husband
acting in a way that's inconsistent with
his word you see your husband setting
goals and failing think about how
transformative it becomes when you stop
getting mad at him for that
and you say hey
i want you to be happy and i want you to
get what you want
and i notice that sometimes you say you
want to do certain things
and you don't do them now it could be
because you change your mind i don't
know and you just didn't let me know or
it could be because you're struggling
with something i'm just curious
like
why why didn't you do that thing that
you said you wanted to do
and if he can feel that non-defensive
curiosity coming from you it creates a
space where he can now open up and say
you know what
i i thought it might offend you if i did
that or i sometimes i feel too tired and
like it's not possible for me or oh you
know what i changed my mind i don't even
want to do that anymore and it creates
an opportunity for you to be
closer to a position of inspiring him
than just being angry because that anger
if you wallow in it will alienate you
but if you can understand it in a way
that says something about your values it
transforms into curiosity and it's
easier to inspire the people around you
did you enjoy this stand-alone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free